I think that there has to be a reckoning
I agree with that America's first drug
is free black labor and turning black
bodies into cotton and the mass
incarceration system mirrors an awful
lot like the blizzard the prison
plantation system that's the same it's a
similar threat your analysis is totally
fair it's historically fair it's
psychologically fair it's economically
fair but you're going to have to come
together as a movement and say here's
what we want done about it I like what
I'm saying is you you what you just said
was a form of victim blaming and you
were saying what the black lives matter
movement needs to do to change white
hearts now I don't talk about look I
don't believe you change hearts I
believe you change laws you change
allocation of resources you change the
way systems operate you're not going to
change every heart you're not
you